كانت تويوتا رائدة في السيارات المكهربة
مع طراز بريوس الهجين لفترة من الوقت ، مما
جعلها تبدو متطورة ولكن
صدق أو لا تصدق أنها لا تبيع حاليًا
سيارة كهربائية بالكامل في الولايات المتحدة ،
هذا هو أول تصميم لها من
الأرض إلى أعلى السيارة الكهربائية  تويوتا
bz4x
اسم فظيع ولكن سيارة عملية بقوة
بطارية تعمل بالبطارية ، تم تصميم bz-4x
منذ البداية كسيارة
كروس أوفر كهربائية ، وهي ليست متكيفة مع
طرازات أخرى ومزودة ببطاريات
تمنحك ما يصل إلى 252 ميلًا من المدى عند
الشحن  وهو أمر جيد ، لا يشتري
الأشخاص سيارات تويوتا من أجل الإثارة
أو لكونهم جميعًا ذوي التكنولوجيا العالية
والمستقبلية يشترون سيارات تويوتا من أجل
نقل آمن وموثوق و bc4x ،
إنه أمر رائع ، أعني أن التصميم الداخلي
أكثر مستقبلية قليلاً في التصميم ، فإن
الركوب قاسي قليلاً.
4x
هي تويوتا سيارات الدفع الرباعي الكهربائية ، لذا فهي
ليست مثيرة ، لكني أحب
السلوك العادي الجيد الشامل لسيارة bz4x ، حتى أنني
وجدت أنها منعشة في عالم
يحاول فيه الكثير من الأشخاص أن يبدوا غير مألوفين.
مقبض حجم andy ومباشر وشاشة لمس كبيرة
لأن كل EV يحتاج إلى شاشة لمس كبيرة على
ما يبدو
بينما يهدف بعض صانعي ev إلى تسريع طائرة مقاتلة
، يستغرق bz4x حوالي سبع
ثوان للوصول من صفر إلى 60 ميلاً في
الساعة وهذا لا يزال سريعًا إلى حد ما في الواقع
لا يحتاج أحد حقًا  للإسراع بشكل أسرع
من ذلك ، فإن ما يزيد قليلاً عن 200 حصان
هو أيضًا أسعار معقولة تمامًا
تبدأ من حوالي 42000
لطراز الدفع بالعجلات الأمامية ، سيتمكن أولئك الذين يشترون
قريبًا من الاستفادة من
ائتمان ضريبي متاح للسيارة الكهربائية
يبلغ 7500 حصان.  لن يفجر عقل أي شخص ،
لكن تويوتا لا تنجح عادةً من خلال
إثارة الذهول ، فهي تنجح من خلال منح العملاء ما يتوقعونه و bz4x هو إلى حد كبير ما
تتوقعه
[موسيقى]